Kiki das kannst du besser die koppenrad
und wiesestatella Kirschtorte ist doch
gar kein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Problem wir starten direkt mit unserem
blitzschokoboden der geht ganz schnell
und ist total Anfänger geeignet falls
übrigens Nebengeräusche hören solltet
wir haben eine kleine Baustelle hier in
der Wohnung aber das hält mich nicht
davon ab diese Torte eins zu ein
nachzumachen ich wir erstmal die Eier in
die Rührschüssel und schlage das Ganze
zusammen mit Zucker richtig schön
[Musik]
hellcremig so nach 2 Minuten in der
Maschine sieht die Masse so aus und
genauso muss sie auch aussehen wenn sie
nicht hell ist und einfach noch zu
kompakt ist dann wird der Teig nicht
schön
saftig oder auch fluffig und da gebe ich
jetzt einmal Sonnenblumenöl mit dazu
falls ihr euch fragt wo stehen die ganz
genau Mengenangaben die stehen bei mir
in allen meinen Videos immer unten in
der Infobox weil das ist so easy dann
könnt euch alle screenshotten einkaufen
und das ganze nachmachen das Öl jetzt
nur für 2 D Sekunden unterrühren und
dann habe ich hier noch vier trockene
Zutaten mehl Speisestärke Backkakao und
Backpulver das Siebe ich mit dazu rühre
das auch noch mal ganz kurz unter und
dann kann auch schon gebacken
[Musik]
werden
so der Teig ist jetzt ready den
Tortenring stelle ich jetzt auf 22 cm
ein das coole ist dass ich mit dem
Tortenring gleich dann auch direkt den
möbelteig ausstechen kann weil der
möbelteig ist ja größer als der
Schokoteig so den Füle ich jetzt hier
ein Streich den schön glatt und dann
wird dem vorgeheizten Backofen einmal
schön gargebacken und dann lst ihn am
besten vollständig
[Musik]
auskühlen ich mache jetzt den möbteig
und ich finde das ist das Beste an einem
Kuchen wenn unten drunter noch so ein
möbelteig ist der noch mit konfettüre
bestrichen wurde und das schreibt doch
ein ernstes letztens jemand nee ich mag
diesen möbteig drunter gar nicht und ich
denke mir so hallo jetzt habe ich mich
vor lauter Aufregung wollte jetzt
eigentlich erst Mehl hier auf die
Arbeitsfläche packen eine kleine mlde
binden Zucker dazu dann habe ich jetzt
die kalte Butter in Stückchen
geschnitten jetzt fange ich erstmal an
zu kneten und geb dann nach und nach
Milch dazu beim letzten koppenradrezept
habe ich den möbelteig mit Ei gemacht
und diesmal dachte mir auch wozu jetzt
noch ein Ei benutzen mache ich jetzt
nicht daher nehme ich jetzt einfach
[Musik]
Milch
der mürbelteig ist fertig ich nehme
jetzt hier direkt mein Backpapier weil
dann habt ihr es einfach leichter später
das auf das Backblech zu geben ich nehme
jetzt einen Durchmesser von 24 cm durch
das Backpapier sehe ich ja hier jetzt
noch meine Durchmesser auf der
silikonbackmatte jetzt nehme ich mir
meinen tetigroller nehme jetzt einfach
noch 6 mm Abstandsringe wenn ihr dieses
ganze Equipment nicht habt dann geht das
auch anders aber so habt ihr halt die
Möglichkeit dass es komplett gleichmäßig
ist und dann aber auch im Ofen
gleichmäßig gar wird und ihr nicht so
eine Ecke höher habt die andere
niedriger und dann ist es einmal
komplett trocken und dann wiederum nicht
ganz durch wenn ihr gerne backt und
leidenschaftliche Hobbybäcker seid dann
könnt ihr euch das ja gerne anschaffen
ich verlinke euch alles in die Infobox
ich rolle jetzt hier aus bis 24 cm und
nehme dann aber meinen Tortenring den
ich auch auf 24 cm einstelle schon mal
und backe das auch darin weil so könnt
ihr auch vermeiden dass euch der
möbelteig so ein bisschen mehr aufgeht
und habt i dann komplett akkurat
gerade so und jetzt steche ich mit der
Gabel ein paar mal ein ich möchte dass
er schön flach bleibt und dann nicht
hochgt und so vermeidet ihr das halt ein
bisschen und jetzt noch mal mein Tipp
weil ihr kennt das ja vom möbetag man
muss den irgendwie erstmal stundenlang
kühlen und darf ihn dann weiter
verarbeiten aber wie ihr seht habe ich
das gar nicht gemacht Trick 17 ich habe
es direkt ausgerollt und geb das jetzt
für 10 Minuten kurz in den Kühlschrank
da kann man sich einfach hier so ein
cakeboard nehmen um das halt rüber zu
transferieren und dann backe ich den und
dann können wir auch schon die
Sahnecreme machen der Schokoboden ist
fertig der möbelteig ist fertig jetzt
fehlt noch unsere straziatella Creme und
in den Zutaten habe ich gesehen es ist
eigentlich nur eine Sahnecreme also
Sahne mit Vanille und ich habe jetzt
hier eiskalte Schlagsahne aus dem
Kühlschrank wenn ihr reine Sahne
aufschlagt ist es natürlich wichtig dass
ihr ein paar Dinge beachtet zum einen
muss die Sahne wirklich komplett kalt
sein haben wir noch mehr Sahne und die
Schüssel sollte auch kalt sein ihr kennt
das ja wenn ihr manchmal die Schüssel
warm abspült und dann wieder benutzen
möchtet das ist dann immer ganz
gefährlich wenn die halt eben noch warm
ist die hier ist richtig schön kalt
abgespült der schneebesenaussatz ist
kalt und jetzt schlage ich erstmal ganz
langsam damit ich nicht ganze Küche voll
Sahne habe also erstmal langsam schlagen
ich kann Zucker aber auch schon mit dazu
geben für die Süße und natürlich ganz
ganz wichtig Vanilleextrakt das macht
hier den ganzen Geschmack aus also ohne
Vanilleextrakt geht hier gar nichts
verlinke ich euch in die Infobox und das
schlage ich dann erstmal langsam auf und
dann bei immer schneller werender
Geschwindigkeit komplett steif schlagen
und währenddessen Sahne fest einrieseln
lassen ihr merkt dass die Sahne soweit
ist wenn ihr den Schneebesen Aufsatz als
Muster in der Sahne seht und nicht
überschlagen weil so ein paar Sekunden
überschlagen bewirken dass das Ganze
grisselig wird und das dann immer
[Musik]
doof so muss die steif geschlagene Sahne
aussehen die wird auch nach der Kühlzeit
noch viel viel fester aber das ist jetzt
erstmal nur Vanillesahne es fehlt ja
noch strazatella weil es ist ja eine
straziatella Kirschtorte und daher geben
wir einfach Schokoraspel mit dazu ob ihr
da vollmch oder Zartbitter neimmt ist
ganz euch überlassen ich habe jetzt hier
Zartbitter und jetzt einmal unterrühren
und jetzt kommt der spaßigste Teil jetzt
wird die Torte einfach nur
zusammengestellt so wir bauen die Torte
jetzt nach und wie man sehen kann also
hier ist ja der möbeteig und direkt da
drüber ist der Boden ich habe aber in
der auf der Rückseite hat bei den
Zutaten gesehen dass da noch
apfelkonfitüre dazwischen kommt normal
ist ja auch Aprikosenkonfitüre also ihr
könnt auch das nehmen was ihr da habt ne
aber ich mach's jetzt wie im Original
und nehmen auch apfelkonfitüre dann
würde ich er mal sagen bauen wir die
Torte zusammen starten hier mit unserem
den kann man richtig gut anheben
übrigens mit unserem möbelteigboden
jetzt ist er übrigens noch so keksig
aber wenn dann alles schön einzieht dann
wird er auch noch richtig schön soft oh
ich liebe das die konfettüre habe ich
kurz in der Mikrowelle erwärmt dann kann
man sie viel besser verstreichen ach so
den Boden muss ich natürlich ich erstmal
halbieren also ich habe den extra flach
gemacht damit ihr den wirklich nur
einmal halbieren müsst und dann haben
wir ja zwei
[Musik]
Böden ich habe das Bild noch mal
inspiziert ich muss sagen da ist eine
dünne Schicht zwischen Mürbteig und
ersten Schokoboden und deswegen mache
ich da jetzt auch eine ganz dünne
Schicht noch dazwischen das wollte ich
einfach nur noch mal gesagt haben wir
machen es ja orinal getreu Leute und in
der Zwischenzeit schreibt mir doch gerne
mal in die Kommentare welche koppenrad
und wiesetrotte als nächstes das kann
aber auch vom lieben dr ögar sein es
muss nicht unbeding koppenrad sein aber
dieses Rezept ist ja auch nur durch euch
entstanden weil ihr mich ja auseinander
genommen habt in den Kommentaren das
muss ich jetzt
essen ja schreib mir do gerne mal und
ich stel mal weiter
hier
[Musik]
die Torte war jetzt noch mal für eine
Stunde bei mir im Kühlschrank damit die
Sahne auch schön fest wird und wie Ihr
sehen können habe ich das extra so ein
bisschen schräg eingestrichen weil das
ja bei der originaltorte auch so ist
jetzt habe ich noch einen Guss
aufgekocht das ist jetzt der kirschpart
tatsächlich ist nicht mehr an Kirsche da
als dieser und der besteht aus
Kirschsaft und ein bisschen Speisestärke
plus Zucker das ganze glat rühren und
einmal aufkochen und ich habe das jetzt
hier einmal noch so 5 Minuten abkühlen
lassen jetzt gebe ich das hier einmal
auf die Oberfläche so und dann am besten
hier mit so einer Winkelpalette einmal
glatt verstreichen ich habe gerade schon
gesagt eine industrielle Torte kann nie
super kompliziert sein sonst ist es ja
unattraktiv für den Handel wenn die da
so 1000 verschiedene Schritte hat ist
echt kein Hexenwerk ich habe jetzt nur
noch für den Rand noch so kleine
schokoperlen einfach optisch jetzt auch
in Vollmilch und weißer Schokolade und
auch zitbitter das GE ich so an den Rand
und dann sind wir durch Leute dann haben
wir es echt schon
[Musik]
geschafft
und habe ich die Challenge gemeistert du
hast so nicht 100 100% gegeben du hast
120% gegeben ja für dich doch immer
bisschen größer ist ja ich muss sagen
aber ich find es besser das do viel zu
klein selst gemacht sind die Torten halt
ein bisschen höher das geht halt irgwie
nicht besser also letzte Mal hast ja
diese maziorte gemacht ne ja Bo die war
richtig lecker hast eigentlich nur für
insta und für tiktok gemacht hätest
eigentlich auch Youtube machen sollen ja
aber das Rezept seht ihr bei Youtube SHS
eigentlich hät auch als rezeptv ja
machen wir noch mehr Druck hier aber
Vergleich richtig schön aus also das ist
jetzt so der Vergleich keine Ahnung was
die da gemacht haben dasund warum haben
die das so runtergemacht si auch nicht
schön aus schön am beschen hier einach
mal ich bin euch ganz ehrlich ich habe
die früher gemocht als Kind und so Kind
halt wow lecker Kuchen ne aber ganz eh
ich fin so selbstgebackene Kuchen immer
leckerer und ich glaube also ich bin
sicher dass das besser ist ein Traum
richtig lecker so richtig frisch und
zart ne so richtig zart einfach nur
frisch die CR schmeckt auch richtig
frisch die Süße ist auch super gar nicht
süß ich glaub Original ist bisschen
süßer also ich habe ja auch ein bisschen
Zucker reduziert ne weil grundsätzlich
diese fertigen Torten gerade auch aus
dem kühregal die sind schon recht süß ne
ich finde das perfekt also die Süße ist
perfek perfek alles ist perfekt also ich
finde das ist ze von ze auf Kaffeetafel
CIA in der Creme ist immer so kleine
Stücke drin ne ich langessen ganz
ehrlich aber das hier und der maipan war
so favorite ja ich muss sagen das waren
auch meine zwei favorite und jetzt
schreib mir doch mal als ich gerade
schon Z aufgerufen hast du gerade ganz
spontan was im Kopf welche Kop und Wiese
Tor ich hab eine ich habe eine im Kopf
gibt diese schwarz der Kirschtorte ist
auch ganz beliebt eigentlich mus stimmt
die ist geil die ist so richtig die
selbstgemacht die ganz ehrlich schreibt
ihr mir das mal rein ich h auf euch weiß
ich gar nicht was gibt von den wir
lassen Benjamin
Blümchen Video alt das kann ich ja noch
mal drehen Bo Leute ich g mir das
Cappuccino richtig richtig lecker macht
unbedingt nach vertraut mir jeder wird
euch lieben wenn ihr diese Torte
nachmacht W Herzen erobern wirklich mach
schick eure Fotos über Instagram auf
jeden Fall tol gemacht und ja danke
schön dann sehen wir uns auch be
nächsten Mal ich immer
dickernk bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
tschüss
ه